we are back with another red magic phone
today we have the red magic 8s Pro
release close to half a year apart from
the red Magic 8 Pro the 8S Pro is here
with a Suave looking back and slightly
different specs compared to the 8 Pro
the similarities between the 8S Pro and
8 Pro on draft stick they both are using
the same screen specs and size RAM and
storage space depends on what you get of
course for the models that we have on
hand the red magic 8s pro has 16 gigs of
RAM and 512 gigs of storage the red
Magic 8 Pro has 12 gigs of RAM and 256
gigs of storage interestingly enough
what separates both phones is that while
they both are equipped with the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 the 8S Pros chip is
overclocked and will prove to have a
speedier performance but other than that
at face value they are practically the
same phone we are going to be running
the 8S Pro through our gaming Gauntlet
of honkai stereo Genji impact Call of
Duty mobile and pubg mobile before we
run the test let's do a baseline of the
temperatures of the front and back of
the phone without Super Chicken
all right currently we're at 90 battery
and we're going to be checking the
temperatures real quick all right 28
28 degrees not too bad not too bad all
right and the back also don't forget we
have a fan inside the phone so that's
going to help out quite a bit
all right moving on and this is a glass
surface so it may be a help to you know
the spell heat a lot quicker who knows
and yeah because honestly the April that
we use was a matte black surface it was
it wasn't glass or anything it was
completely matte so we'll maybe see a
difference with this packing all right
I was checking this real quick also we
have the info screen up on the top here
in the middle so you guys can see what's
up and let's just check our settings
real quick I've set everything to very
high for our settings the only reason
why it's custom is because FPS by
default v30 it's on 60 right now and
yeah I guess we're good to go
wait
all right same thing
synthetic universe
okay so so far everything's looking
pretty good so before we get spotted and
you just do a quick check of which is
how it's uniform and he looks really
good here
oh yeah
they're detailing on this little clock
here it's gone it's it's all you show
the pauldrons looks really good and this
is a pretty smooth if I flick around the
camera nothing yep no train stopping
whatsoever so let's move on
again
[Applause]
[Music]
we're just fun
[Applause]
especially real quick
well you gotta make it worth my while
[Applause]
all right very nice
okay so gameplay
[Music]
so far is very smooth and it's getting
good thanks to that overclocks that
dragon eat Gen 2 so we're gonna keep
moving
[Music]
[Applause]
this ends here
here
[Applause]
[Music]
that's good
it should be enough I hope okay just one
more round oh oh you're done okay sit
moving on
[Applause]
okay
check them up stack them up stack them
all up
[Music]
[Applause]
20 minutes in 94 battery
roll
[Applause]
[Music]
s
[Applause]
so it's the first boss down
and oh the last one as well come on come
on come on
there we go that's it okay these played
for about 28 minutes
right now it is noticeably warm but it's
not warm enough to make me want to put
it down it's quite nice here and also
the fan here has been looking over time
as well so let's just check the front
real quick
[Music]
all right 37.5 pretty soon all right
numbers need to be okay actually
it's not the worst it's not the worst
but one of the few better ones out there
that you can beat so far
look at that
pretty good all right turn it over
you can do a smudge measure obviously so
you know confused
35 and let's see what the hell the fan
is right there's a 37
this size about
378 on the other side but it's still
liquids Magic
get yourself
so with that let's move to our next game
against impact
and right now hot off the heels of Hong
Kong stereo let's check temperatures
real quick let's put this down and
well 34. it's dissipated quite quick
wow okay
yeah that's a
almost four to five degree decrease from
what we just saw check the back
wow
okay this thing does a really good job
at anticipating Heat
damn
okay
all right all right all right all right
okay and with that
um the engine impact all right here we
go
okay so okay let's check something so
quick just let me confirm things uh
Graphics we are sending everything to
high 60 FPS oh so now that it's daytime
look at this it is beautiful the sun is
not questing over but it is a great
morning
by the sun bounces off there's all
details here and there
but it's really good all the screws can
be falling off no huge thing drops
try that
she can play around a lot practically
not much of an issue no nothing at all
okay so let's run through town and see
how well this comes up oh yeah a little
bit of frame something you know just
it was a slightly
yeah you can see there is quite a bit
more now
as I keep dashing
[Applause]
not too bad but you can see the
performance jump a little bit here and
there
oh yeah okay so this could be like a six
FPS drop right there
let's even get again
[Applause]
so yeah you got about two or five full
instruction there
but
nothing to be too concerned about I
think that it feels fine it's very
smooth and with that let's move on to
exploration and maybe a bit of calm down
okay
[Applause]
yep nice speed myself up a little bit
okay so on a couple of these back to
back
it is
[Applause]
one with wind and clouds
all right nice okay I think we combat
when you stack up all the different alt
Keys like you know you will go into some
trouble to be honest there aren't that
many phones out there that I have tried
that can honestly handle a lot of kimchi
stuff especially when you're trying to
stack up like two old piece at the same
challenge you want to see the other back
to that you know it will kind of push
your phone to its limits as you see so
you do expect for yourself to expect
fairly drops it's going to an impact
right okay Excursion wire is another bit
is beautiful as we've walked around and
rendering distance is great so let's
just move on to the Inspire the base
[Music]
great
[Applause]
okay
let's take up all the openings
[Applause]
all this stuff
I mean obviously you know I enjoyed the
wrestler and I really am enjoying this
one now
three years
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's hopping off the engine
impact let's check out just real quick
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
doing pretty well
maybe a lot better than what you did
see the back take the back
not wow okay
it's not more than expecting to be
honest
okay okay all right wow okay damn right
magic and I would still prefer the
textured mat back and with the inclusion
of this fan here but yeah this is this
is great and with that let's move to our
next game Call of Duty mobile before we
continue this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for the
sponsored message if you are looking for
a laptop that does it all gaming
streaming and content creation then look
no further than the Rog Zephyrs M16 the
first 16 inch laptop with an anime
Matrix LED array so you can showcase
your inner geek to the World featuring a
16 by 10 aspect ratio QHD Pantone
validated Rog nebula display this
display not only looks great but also
offers unprecedented performance thanks
to its 240Hz refresh rate and three
milliseconds response time with all that
power comes a full width heatsink
supported by Rog intelligent cooling
with tri-fan technology to keep the
laptop cool while intense gaming or
heavy workloads for more details check
out asus.com part of the heels of
Kenshin impact let's check temperatures
real quick
right front 33 34 doing pretty well
pretty good pretty good all right France
dissipating heat pretty damn well let's
check it back
31 wow 32 32
ethi gonna push up to 33 no okay we're
doing pretty good pretty good pretty
good pretty good all right
with that let's move on to Call of Duty
mobile alright so we're at the front
page the Navy looks really good look at
how the light reflects off the air max
over here and off her face and a leather
jacket which looks really good all right
set things real quick let's check those
Graphics all right so um Google Ultra
favorite as many people you want that
and medium core because at least even
cross the higher Ultra I mean uh Battle
Royale everything's on turn on and yeah
that's all we need actually 285 battery
so let's go for round of VR
see how it goes let's see where we drop
honestly I've been doing this
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
so that's fun
I'm pretty good
okay I'm moving down no hearing drops
nothing I mean honestly pushing for the
match but this game is really smooth
this way
all right
okay this is nice
very nice I believe this is a bus fire
rifle
which I'm not too fond of but it is what
it is let's keep moving
but as you can see with the inclusion of
these editors the same as the eights
these are super smooth and very helpful
[Applause]
ready
sticking down
it's been delivered
[Applause]
oh I see him
okay we're gonna hit
a break nice
let's keep pushing
[Music]
let's check out some pictures real quick
[Applause]
35.
[Music]
50 all right I'm honestly it's not gonna
heat you up at all it's actually very
comfortable here that hand
all right let's check the back 32 31 32
yeah this thing's doing rolling fine
[Applause]
let them know
spread the love spread the pain
[Applause]
there we go let's see down
very action-packed
okay so uh that number has gone on quite
a bit all right two teams left it's Us
and Them
wherever they miss
they're definitely on the other end
oh where
Oh serious here serious you
there we go
hey yeah we've won all right so with
that let's check temperature at 79 we've
been through three games already
temperatures
all right
okay not bad I feel not bad I mean kind
of like Call of Duty on whatever
settings but you know it's not the
highest settings but it plays up very
smoothly no frame start the ring no
frame rate drops nothing
this baby can put anything you throw at
it against it a little bit iffy at this
point but other than that I'm still
doing pretty good all right but that
final game
pubg mobile temperature check
so the front right now
here at 31.5 doing pretty I mean it
disability again very well all right
let's check the back
look at those numbers goddamn
that is delicious all right
no huge heat spikes nothing and
everything still feels cool to the touch
or at least you know comfortably warm in
your hands all right with that let's
check those settings we're in the menu
right now settings okay all right so
settings wise we are smooth for graphics
and maybe FPS photos empty aliasing and
everything looks pretty pretty sad and
also we're at 70 right now for battery
so
just jump into the gym
so uh before the match starts you know
looks pretty good very smooth no issues
whatsoever
all right everyone's naked great
given the settings you're on and you
know it's a cheering free damn speed
obviously this camera can catch 90 FPS
and whatever you guys can see maybe FPS
on your end but yeah
so it enjoys
all right let me do the book
for the first time in a long while I am
finally not the gym leader in this video
but yeah looking pretty good look at
that
no issues no framing drops nothing yeah
but yeah expecting I'm not expecting
this to you know really take a huge
chunk out of the performance of the real
magic videos Pro but let's see
it'll do fine
all right uh coming a bit too low
actually
oh boy okay
straight for those houses over there
and we have one guy he has landed
further off first coming in towards the
house so
um uh hopefully this house is stuff I
can use
get in getting get in
okay technically they're they're asked
oh okay yep let's kill this guy come on
[Applause]
come on
okay let's first kill nice
okay oh
damn oh okay see you now
oh a nice little gunfire getting into
I'm actually really enjoying myself
playing with this thing the extra
because I will keep magnificently and
you know what uh with this much peace
I'm I know
you know
let's check temperatures real quick
okay uh 30.734 nothing too crazy I mean
that's also it's a combination of like
you know the heat of my hands okay so
um we check the front we'll check the
back yet
but uh you're pretty good
uh I have no idea where those shots came
from behind me obviously but I have no
idea where they originated from
definition
okay
[Applause]
I'll come again on the left side
oh
there you go oh
a bit of bum rushing while you can
[Applause]
oh my God okay
okay this one day
[Applause]
okay
oh boy
oh there we go
all right
so there's a couple more left only
bro
[Applause]
all right nice
all right I found one of them
[Applause]
oh
there we go
ah nice all right we're now with a
chicken dinner oh my God final
temperatures before we move on to our
final thoughts
all right 34.
feeling pretty good
[Applause]
36 nothing too drastic performance has
been amazing let's check the back real
quick
ah 31.4 31 nothing drastic you know
we're doing pretty damn well all right
and also on that note we are currently
at 67 battery after four games and
basically I was playing for about an
hour 44 minutes or so so we're doing
pretty damn good on time on battery
everything so with that let's move on to
my final thoughts the red magic 8s does
prove to be the faster and sleeker phone
thanks to its overclock Snapchat and 8
Gen 2 processor and it's beautiful
transparent design which is you know as
you can see it's a bit of a smudge
magnet however it looks a lot better
than the back of the 8 Pro the red Magic
series of phones already stand out with
this internal fan and rugged Aesthetics
coupled that in with the usual red magic
finesse of their touch triggers and
customizability the red magic 8s pro has
everything you need to keep your friends
jealous and opponents pinned down but
more importantly what do you think with
the 8 Pro still entice you of which you
want to make the younger but faster
sibling the 8S Pro during next best
purchase leave your answers and any
questions you have in the comment
section below and if you like what we do
make sure to follow us on all of our
socials right here to keep up to date
with what we do and maybe leave a like
and hit that subscribe button it goes a
long way if you want to see more stuff
check this out
[Music]
foreign